make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back with part two of our
marvel cosmic hierarchy series
and i have no idea how this video is
performing because i am
not recording this the next day
i think i just finished recording the
last one like five minutes ago right so
it could be that these are doing
horribly and i'm just like well that
sucks when i look at them later and it
could be that they're doing swimmingly
which is cool but regardless we're
picking back up again with our series
and this time we're starting with number
15
on our list of the most powerful beings
that exist in the entirety of the marvel
multiverse and on number 15 here i've
got the living tribunal now the letting
tribunal he was a tough one to place
right it was it was kind of tough to
place him um i initially i was kind of
inclined to go with
classic living tribunal but the only
time we ever really saw anything
significant when it came to the classic
living tribunal is we saw him like shut
down the infinity gauntlet which is a
universal wide source of power so that's
not really impressive when you're
talking about the kind of things that
you see
multiversal characters doing especially
when we get further down the list and we
start talking about
how op some of these guys are um but
again you know when you look at like the
the more modern version of the living
tribunal you still see
some pretty you know some relatively
impressive things happening but the
reality is the living tribunal seems to
be one of these characters in marvel it
just kind of skirts by
based on the role he plays or the role
that's been established for him as
opposed to the power you see him using
when he is
you know involved in these various wars
we did see an instance where he held
like two mega universes apart rightly on
two two megaverses so like two
multiverse multiverses apart which i
guess is it's cool
when you look at the you know look at
this in comparison to other things but
as we get further through the list
i think you're gonna find that's not
really all that impressive either the
living tribunal kind of exists as a
judge of the multiverse but just because
he was designed to serve a certain role
does not necessarily mean that there are
individuals out there that are incapable
of becoming more powerful than he is
and over the time that we've seen marvel
comics existing and the various
characters that have been introduced a
lot of folks are more powerful here so
this guy was a tough sell it was kind of
it was kind of hard to figure out
exactly where to put him but i think
this is a pretty good spot here at the
number 15 location
because what we have above him is
nightmare now normally i would
never have put nightmare above the
living tribunal and i'm sure some of you
guys are just like
what i would never would have put
nightmare above the living tribunal
except that we recently saw nightmare
overpower the living tribunal and that
was during the alex ross story where you
essentially have nightmare capturing
doctor strange and then
basically putting everybody in existence
to sleep and then feeding off the power
that they
basically emanate to his realm while
they are asleep and then you see him
take out all the cosmic entities and
galactus and the living tribunal
that one feat alone is the reason why i
have him above the living tribunal if
that hadn't happened he wouldn't even
been on this list
it's the only reason why he's here now
it is a one-off and that's kind of the
funny thing
is if this was something like him
assembling you know like the infinity
gauntlet and then somehow boosting its
powers
in such a way to where it could never
really happen again then i would
consider it a one-off and i would wipe
it away and i would say
nope but when when the ability for him
to overpower the living tribunal and
everybody else that we've seen on this
list when it all hails from the fact
that he managed to get the world to fall
asleep
by manipulating dr strange that's not
that outside the realm of possibility to
occur
a second time over somebody else to do
something similar and so i think there's
a legitimate case to be made here that
this is not just a one-off it's not just
a happenstance kind of thing
that it is a repeatable concept and it
could happen again
believably right it could happen again
and it could be like okay i could
definitely see him doing that if he's
able to ensnare the right kind of person
and use them for his own ends i could
definitely see that taking place and so
because of that
i think this is a good spot to put him
now above him
and this one's going to be a little a
little wonky i'm putting the black
winter
right the black winter is the choice
that i'm putting above nightmare
and here's the reason why i'm putting
this guy here the black winner as he was
introduced in donnie kate's thor run at
least the first story arc of donnie
case's thor run
is he was given to us as a guy who was
just kind of going through the
multiverse and destroying and consuming
entire universes
the way the galactus consumes worlds now
we it basically means he has a role to
play or it seems like he has a role to
play within the multiverse the biggest
problem that we have with this
is there are too many unanswered
questions i'm going here just on
sheer abilities right the fact that he
was able to just consume
entire universes and kind of destroy
them uh and there wasn't really anybody
who could stand in his way no cosmic
entities no nothing right it just showed
up consumed the universe and then left
um the sheer amount of power it takes to
do that is pretty astronomical we've
never seen
him face off against nightmare or the
living tribunal so i'm really just kind
of doing this and putting him here in
relation to the fact that you know when
it comes to some of the stuff that we've
seen we've seen the living tribunal
destroy universes we've seen nightmare
you know
presumably because he was able to defeat
the living tribunal he possesses that
same power as well
what makes the black winter so
intriguing here is because of the fact
that we don't know his origin
we don't know exactly where he comes
from or why he exists the way that he
does it's something just the black
winter is there right and the black
winner just
does some things the reality is i think
it'll play more of a role later on in
donnie kate's run
so this spot is really more tentative
because it could be one of these things
that if the living tribunal exists and
the living tribunal's purpose
is to judge the multiverse and to make
sure there's no mystical imbalance or
any kind of imbalance in terms of power
and you have the black winter traveling
around the multiverse and then
destroying it if he's like a foreign
body so like the equivalent of you
catching a cold and he's not
actually supposed to be doing that the
living tribunal would presumably step in
and so if that's the if
that didn't happen only one of two
things can really be believed here
either the living tribunal chose not to
step in because that's the role the
black winter plays or the living
tribunal was incapable of stepping in
because there was nothing the living
tribunal could have done
i'm erring on the second one here like
i'm just kind of going with a second
possibility that there was nothing the
living tribunal could do to stop the
black winter and just kind of went
through but then if that's the case
that begs the question how did galactus
kill it right so that's that's one of
the the wonky situations about a
character like this is
the the kind of things that we've seen
him do makes him absurdly powerful but
the way in which he died
is kind of silly at the same time right
so it's one of those things where you
can kind of go either way but beyond the
black winter this is when things kind of
get a little bit more to familiarity and
some names you guys know uh but also
pretty crazy at the same time right so
the next person to come after this i'm
going with
god king doom right god king doom right
here number 12
on our list i know it's kind of far down
it's it's pretty far down and you would
expect
more out of god king doom but at this
point we're really just going on the
kinds of things that we've seen them do
god king doom the funny thing about him
is we didn't really see him do
anything crazy impressive the most
impressive thing we saw him do
actually happened off panel when he
basically took the pieces of the
multiverse and then brought them
together
into one single world but if you're
talking about a person that has the
ability to manipulate a multiverse
that's not special right the living
tribunal could do that if for some
reason the multiverse was destroyed and
he survived the experience that's not
unreasonable
right so that's not a ridiculous display
of power
in my book it's basically just salvaging
what's left right just summoning the
bits of the multiverse i mean when you
compare them to some universal concepts
sure but to the other people on this
list it's not super impressive to me
because they could all basically do the
same thing um
we saw him like destroy thanos but all
he did was just punch him through the
chest and then disintegrate him one of
the crazy things is that we actually saw
god king doom's power going on par with
the power of the infinity gauntlet if
you guys remember that from secret wars
in 2015.
and so when you take this the fact that
he was kind of equal to the infinity
gauntlet power as it was presented but
then you also take into
to consideration the nature of god king
doom and this is one of those arguments
where we have to argue the circumstance
that the display of power that we saw
from god king doom didn't necessitate
him using the full totality of his power
and the reason why is because god king
doom was really it was really more of a
funnel that was giving him his abilities
right in the form of the molecule man
owen reese that what you had out there
is the next group on our list which are
the beyonders right the beyonders the
energy that made uh made them everything
they were and all the power that they
had
just kind of coalesced and existed out
there you know and and the molecule man
owen reese funneled that power to doctor
doom but he couldn't funnel the full
totality of that power into doctor doom
otherwise it would kill him and so
assuming that dr doom found some way to
do that he'd have the full totality of
the honors of his abilities and he'd be
virtually unstoppable but the reason why
i'm also kind of putting him here is
because
seemingly anybody that can channel the
power of the beyonders is a person who's
above the living tribunal
quite easily and especially nightmare or
black winter or anybody like that
because when the beyonders came in the
beyonders killed the living tribunal
they killed all the cosmic entities that
killed the celestials they killed
eternity they killed infinity they
killed all the cosmic entities
across the whole multiverse so these
guys were wildly op
they were hugely powerful and when
you're talking about a power on that
scale even having a fraction of it
should be more than sufficient enough to
destroy virtually any cosmic entity or
being that exists out there
including the living tribunal but again
we never really saw dr doom use his
power to that full totality so
this is one of those circumstances where
he's in the number 12 spot not so much
because of what we saw him do but
because of the potential of what he
could do and so that's why we also have
the beyonders sitting at number 11.
because with these guys they were just
on a whole new level of power right a
level of power that we just hadn't
really seen before and this is when
things are going to get kind of bonkers
because from this point going forward in
the other videos that we're making
there really isn't a huge distinction of
power between the the beyonders and
anybody else it's really more of how
they use that power and how quickly they
were able to do the kind of things they
did right and the fact that the way they
were depicted is they were effectively
second to none this would become
particularly important when we get to a
guy who
named himself after the living
embodiment of death with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end if you are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
foreign